[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la Une de Paris
sacrété les ce mois-ci software
République cette écosystème d'innovation
veut façonner la mobilité de demain
cette alliance inédite de grands groupes
s'est formé autour de Renault qui veut
donc accompagner la révolution
automobile on vous explique comment dans
un instant le pari sacré spring c'est
bientôt le 1er juin à HEC et qui dit
Paris Saclay spring dit spring 50 50
startups qui sont mises à l'honneur et
on connaît le parrain de cette édition
de cette promotion 2023 il s'agit de
Jean-Luc Maria le co-fondateur et CEO
d'exoterelle une start-up qui fait
partie de l'industrie newspace ce
logisticien de l'espace veut lutter
contre la pollution sp iale et enfin
vous entendrez le témoignage de l'un des
lauréats du Spring 50 de l'année
dernière circule egg est une entreprise
pionnière dans l'économie circulaire
elle recycle elle transforme les déchets
issus des coquilles de c'est plutôt
malin voilà pour le programme il y aura
bien sûr notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission pareil sa clé TV c'est
parti
[Musique]
on commence cette émission avec software
République cet écosystème d'innovation
veut accompagner la révolution
automobile mettre au point cette
mobilité de Point Zéro Renault c'est
donc entouré de grands groupes comme
Thalès Atos d'aosystème orange St micro
une alliance inédite pour des projets
ambitieux par exemple comment récupérer
les données de nos véhicules pour mieux
sécuriser les routes ou mettre au point
une borne de recharge électrique
bidirectionnelle innovante pour en
savoir plus nous avons rencontré Eric
flottin c'est le directeur des
opérations de software République
[Musique]
République c'est l'écosystème
d'innovation concret le groupe Renault
Thalès orange Dassault Systèmes
stmicroelectronique et Atos il y a
maintenant pas loin de 2 ans l'idée
c'est de transformer la mobilité à
travers des produits des services très
concrets qui sont développés en grande
partie autour de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque
beaucoup des partenaires que je viens de
citer sont fortement implantés dans ce
dans ce territoire et donc on a lancé
déjà cinq produits cinq services dans
des domaines très variés comme la
cybersécurité comme les bornes de
recharge et aussi comme l'accompagnement
des territoires et en particulier le
territoire de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin sur l'utilisation des
données pour améliorer le service aux
citoyens améliorer le trafic améliorer
l'état des routes etc donc des choses
très concrètes et opérationnelles qui
impactent le territoire
dans les exemples parlant des
réalisations on va lancer là au mois de
septembre une borne de recharge
innovante cette borne de recharge elle
va finalement permettre à ce que la
voiture non seulement consomme de
l'énergie quand on a besoin de se
recharger mais qu'elle l'aide aussi la
maison ou le réseau a passé les pics de
consommation c'est ce qu'on appelle une
borne bidirectionnelle et finalement ça
va non pas faire que le véhicule
électrique soit un problème pour le
réseau ou au contraire une solution pour
aider à la stabilisation du réseau ça
c'est un exemple très concret le
deuxième c'est celui qui a pas
directement les territoires comme
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous avez tous
vu sur les routes des câbles noirs qui
comptent les voitures mesure leur
vitesse aujourd'hui à travers des
données anonymisées des voitures des
cartes SIM des téléphones qui se
déplacent d'orange et bien on arrive
très simplement à avoir accès à ces
données de manière très flexible très
rapide et pour permettre à la
collectivité et bien de réagir pour
organiser au mieux le transport
vis-à-vis des citoyens et dans des coûts
plus maîtrisés possible et on a aussi
d'assosystème qui vient permettre
derrière d'avoir des outils de
simulation et de planification de ces
transports grâce à ces données donc on
voit qu'on passe dans la mobilité 2.0
avec sauf la République
toutes ces actions concrètes elles se
déploie au cours de l'année 2023 sur le
terrain et puis on a plein de nouveaux
projets de nouveaux business de nouveaux
services qu'on fera ravis de vous
présenter et en avant-première je peux
vous dire que je vous donne rendez-vous
le 14 juin à vive tech ou nous aurons
plein plein de choses très sympa en très
ancré sur le territoire à vous montrer à
tous
[Musique]
on s'arrête maintenant sur le Paris
Saclay spring c'est le premier joint à
HEC parmi les temps forts il y a bien
sûr le Spring 50 50 startups du
territoire qui sont mises en avant qui
sont sélectionnés le parrain cette année
c'est Jean-Luc Maria il a accepté de
relever le défi c'est le co-fondateur
essayo d'exo trail ce logisticien de
l'espace a démarré ici sur le campus sur
le plateau de Paris-Saclay il revient
sur ses débuts et il nous explique
comment il veut lutter contre la
pollution spatiale
[Musique]
on a une société spécialisée sur le
sujet de la mobilité mais dans l'espace
donc en fait tous les objets les
satellites donc déjà il y en a de plus
en plus dans l'espace pour répondre à
des besoins terrestres de connectivité
d'observation de la Terre d'exploration
au sens large et en fait tous ces objets
au-delà de leur mouvement naturel autour
de la Terre il va falloir les bouger
tout au long de leur vie d'abord en
début de vie pour rejoindre les orbites
sur lequel ils vont fonctionner ensuite
les maintenir sur l'orbite et puis en
fin de vie de plus en plus il va falloir
faire quelque chose de ces objets soit
les mettre sur des orbites parking soit
les faire redescendre pour pouvoir
éviter en fait de polluer l'espace et en
fait tout ça c'est de la mobilité et exo
trail ce spécialise sur l'organisation
de cette mobilité et ça c'est la
définition de la logistique donc
exotrail c'est une société de logistique
spatiale
on est un pur produit de Paris-Saclay
parce qu'en fait on a démarré sur le
plateau en 2015 ou en fait on a réuni un
ensemble d'établissements de Paris
Saclay donc l'École polytechnique le
CNRS l'observatoire de Versailles 51 en
Yvelines en particulier l'université de
Versailles 51 en Yvelines le 5 retrans
soleil et en fait on a proposé un projet
à l'organisme de transfert de
technologie de Paris-Saclay la SAT et
c'est à partir de là qu'on a commencé en
fait à travailler sur l'un de nos
premiers produits c'est un propulseur
pour le marché des petits satellites et
donc on a démarré au sein du CNRS avec
tous les établissements que j'ai
mentionnés et de fil en aiguille on a
commencé à obtenir des bons résultats et
la voix de valorisation en fait de ce
projet ça a été la création d'une
entreprise exotrail qu'on a
officiellement créé en 2017
donc après la création de l'entreprise
on s'est d'abord installé à l'incubateur
à l'accélérateur de Polytechnique donc
le centre dry et puis en 2018 en fait on
s'installe ici à Massy en même temps on
s'installe à Toulouse c'est une
particularité de l'entreprise depuis nos
débuts on est sur les deux sites et j'en
ai aujourd'hui une centaine de personnes
donc à peu près les deux tiers des
effectifs à Massy ici et puis un tiers à
Toulouse et on a du coup progressé très
vite
création du coût de l'entreprise en 2017
sans personne en 2023 et on a une
ambition afin 2023 d'être à peu près 160
personnes
je suis ravi de d'être parrain de cette
promotion à 2023 de Spring 50 il y a
plusieurs éléments le premier c'est la
thématique spatiale en particulier qui
est mis qui est mis en valeur il y a
beaucoup de compétences sur le
Paris-Saclay au sens large dans le
domaine spatial il y a un énorme
potentiel créé un pôle spatial de rang
international on a tous les ingrédients
pour ça on a des très bons laboratoires
de recherche des entités de recherche on
a des écoles on a des universités on a
des centres de recherche privées qui se
sont beaucoup installés et puis on a des
startups aujourd'hui comme exo trail on
n'est pas les seuls issus de Paris
sacrés il y en a d'autres et au-delà de
ça le potentiel global de Paris-Saclay
et bien au-delà de cette thématique
spatiale cette richesse des domaines de
recherche couverts par Paris-Saclay
permet effectivement aujourd'hui
l'émergence de beaucoup de projets de
start-up
issus de Paris-Saclay dans des domaines
complètement différents que ce soit de
l'intelligence artificielle de la
robotique des sciences potentiellement
humaines et sociales etc et donc je suis
ravi de pouvoir démontrer que on peut
issu de Paris-Saclay faire un projet
entrepreneurial qui aujourd'hui est dans
une phase de croissance
internationalisation et qui est final
très ambitieux sur une thématique en
particulier qui est spatiale
[Musique]
parmi les cinq lauréats du sprint 50 de
l'année dernière il y a circulaire une
start-up qui est née sur les bancs de
l'école agro ParisTech qui fait partie
du Campus Paris Saclay cette entreprise
elle s'intéresse aux 40.000 tonnes de
coquilles de qui s'entassent dans les
casseries Françaises un biodéchet qui
est bourré de biominéraux de molécules
encore faut-il les récupérer les
transformer voyons comment avec Yacine
kabèche qui est le fondateur de circule
egg
[Musique]
je suis Yassine cadh le fondateur et SIO
de l'entreprise circule ei
[Musique]
en fait notre coquille est constitué de
deux parties la coque est externe la
coquille externe est riche à 98% de
carbonate de calcium en gros c'est du
calcium et on la propose en alternative
au coeur bonheur de calcium qui provient
aujourd'hui majoritairement des
carrières de calcaire on a donc un
meilleur impact sur mental et on a de
meilleures propriétés nutritionnelles le
deuxième produit c'est la membrane
interne l'avant-bras interne elle est
riche en différentes biomolécules
d'intérêts avec le collagène l'acide
hyaluronique et cette membrane elle a
des propriétés prouvées pour ce qu'on
appelle le soutien de la fonction
articulaire et la bonne santé de la peau
alors aujourd'hui en fait on vend notre
ingrédient pour d'autres industriels qui
souhaitent avoir des ingrédients
biosourcés recyclés et décarbonés
concrètement aujourd'hui c'est
l'industrie des matériaux l'industrie du
complément alimentaire humain
l'industrie du pet food et de la
cosmétique
Paris Saclay en fait c'est dès la
jeunesse du projet il faut savoir
circuler il est né sur les bancs d'une
des écoles du réseau Paris-Saclay c'est
à savoir accro par les tech ou quand
j'étais étudiant un groupe à high-tech
j'ai développé le procédé avec des
laboratoires partenaires de
AgroParisTech et donc de Paris Saclay au
sens large et aujourd'hui on travaille
encore avec ses laboratoires on
travaille aussi avec des entreprises qui
sont situées sur le plateau de sa clé
qui sont aujourd'hui nos clients donc
aujourd'hui on a différents types de
partenariats que ce soit de la recherche
publique de la recherche privée et aussi
de développement commercial avec des
entreprises qui font partie de notre
plateau de Saclay à savoir notamment le
secteur du Food
l'année dernière on a eu la chance de
pouvoir participer au sprint 50 en tant
que exposant on avait notre lame de
premier stands et aussi et surtout on a
été lauréat du concours sprint 50 ça a
été intéressant pour différentes choses
bon déjà pour la visibilité que nous a
permis le sprint 50 mais aussi toutes
les mises en relation avec les
entreprises qui sont nos clients
aujourd'hui et des fonds
d'investissement qui sont aujourd'hui à
bord ce qu'on espère du futur sprint 50
c'est exactement la même chose donc
continuer des mises en relation
pertinentes pour votre business
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent la data ne pas
rater vous le savez c'est le 1er juin le
Paris Saclay spring il faut s'inscrire
pour participer à l'événement sinon si
vous aimez le vélo et si vous voulez
profiter de ce joli mois de mai et bien
il y a l'opération parlons vélo c'est le
11 mai au Pavillon réciproque c'est de
16h à 19h30 à Palaiseau le PA participe
à cette édition un kit de réparation de
vélo mobile sera même mis à disposition
des personnes qui voudraient y
participer elles seront assistées par la
recycléorie sportive de Massy pour la
prise en main du dispositif c'est aussi
le printemps le printemps de l'agglo
l'agglomération paris-saclet et les
villes vous invite à un véritable
festival nature alors vous avez du temps
puisque c'est du 9 mai au 30 juin il y a
des balades à vélo des observations de
la faune et de la flore un concours de
photos et bien d'autres activités et
temps forts de ces deux mois de fête le
vendredi 23 juin à partir de 17h30 au
siège de l'agglomération Paris Saclay et
enfin si vous portez un projet
d'innovation technologique ou de
services si vous dirigez une start-up en
face de croissance ce qui club vous
présente ces programmes d'incubation et
d'accélération pour lancer ou consolider
votre start-up rendez-vous et prix le 8
juin et voilà c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission merci de votre attention merci
de votre fidélité on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de Paris sa
clé TV
[Musique]